-This is what people
are talking about, you guys.
Some big news about
the Russia investigation.
It came out that Robert Mueller
wants to interview
President Trump.
It's gonna be awkward
when Trump tries to flee
to Mexico and can't climb
over his own wall.
[ As Trump ] I knew I should
have added doggy doors.
[ Normal voice ] What?
You guys see this?
After reports that the
FBI lost some text messages
between two FBI agents involved
with this, Trump tweeted...
The president blames
Samsung for the lost texts.
It was not the first time
he's gone on Twitter
to blame a company
for something.
For example,
Trump once tweeted...
-Wow!
-He's blaming --
-He's blaming Velveeta.
-Blaming Velveeta.
-The Kraft Corporation.
-He also tweeted...
-Wow!
-And, finally, he tweeted...
He won't own up to anything.
-Yeah.
-He's blaming Isotoners.
But, tonight, Trump
is flying to Switzerland
for The World Economic Forum,
and the flight's supposed
to last eight hours,
or, as they told Trump,
16 "SpongeBobs."
[ As Trump ] Okay.
Okay.
But there are a lots
of protests in Switzerland.
One person was holding a
sign that said "Dump Trump."
But the president wasn't mad.
He said, "Ha ha.
You spelled Donald wrong.
There's two P's."
I want to say congrats
to Senator Tammy Duckworth,
who will become
the first U.S. Senator
to have a baby while in office.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Isn't that great?
That's right.
She's having a baby,
so at least we've got
one Senator will who deliver.
-Hey-oh! Ho! Hey! Ho!
-Check this out, guys.
Pizza Hut says
if either team beats the record
for the fastest touchdown
in the Super Bowl,
it's giving away free pizza to
people in its loyalty program.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The only downside is --
you have to tell people
that you're in the
Pizza Hut loyalty program.
I guess someone else must have
signed me up for that.
I don't remember.
-"Can you punch my card?"
-This was pretty big today.
Elton John just announced
that he's going to retire
after his next world tour.
There's going to be a
very dramatic moment at the end,
where he admits that
the lyrics really are
"hold me closer, Tony Danza."
I heard that.
That's from a source,
a good source.
Finally, I saw that two guys
in Minnesota were pulled over
with almost 500 pounds of
weed in their car.
500 pounds.
You could tell it was a lot,
'cause even their GPS was like,
"Forget about the destination.
It's all about
the journey, man."
We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots!